[Music]
coming up next on c-span a live viewer
call-in program our guest is jefferson
morley a washington editor for the
nation
he will discuss an article he wrote for
the new republic titled what is crack
like
we invite you to call us with your
questions and your comments
[Music]
jefferson morley
of the nation magazine
and last week's
new republic
your former publication you write an
article that has a headline what crack
is like
first sentence when it comes to crack
politicians and pundits literally do not
know what they're talking about
what else did you say uh it's it's
absolutely true crack is a phenomenon
obviously very important very serious
problem in society today and all the
people who talk about it know nothing
about it so as a reporter
i wanted to find out about what
what this problem is why people are
using this drug go to the people who are
doing it so i went out and smoked crack
this is part of a long journalistic
tradition of journalists going out and
seeing the problems firsthand goes back
to the progressive era when reporters
went to the slums went to the meat
packing factories go out there and see
what's really going on not to take the
word of government official
self-interested bureaucrats but to find
out what are the people involved what
are they going through that's what this
article is about you wrote crack is a
pleasure both powerful and elusive
smoke a rock and for the next 20 minutes
you will likely appreciate sensuous
phenomena ranging from mtv to neon
lights to oral sex with renewed urgency
this is nothing new
people have known that crack is a
pleasurable drug and i went out and
found the same thing the thing that i
would emphasize from my personal
experience with craig is
one
that it's a very short-lived thing
which is interesting why are people
going after something that doesn't last
very long second it's a very depressing
culture of late night
rendezvous to desperately try and buy
little tiny amounts of drugs people who
have very little money people are living
in abandoned buildings
this is all part of the crack phenomenon
and it all has to be understood when did
you smoke crack sometime in the last
year
in your article you describe
what a night of
crack use yeah crack use okay tell us
about that night well i think it's
important i didn't want to just go and
use crack off in isolation i'm trying to
find out as a reporter i'm trying to
find out about the phenomenon what's
this world like we hear so much about it
but i think a lot of times we hear it
second hand from
self-interested bureaucrats
from
drug
rehabilitation experts
i thought it was important to go out and
see it firsthand
so in a
in the urban setting late night spent
time with people whose lives are
consumed by
by crack
that's what that's what that's the
reality of this world and i don't think
i'm doing anything too unusual and going
out there uh and uh and seeing this
world i think what's unusual about my
article is that somebody's speaking
in a new and in my opinion more honest
way about the drug problem that's out
there did you do it in this town
no
you say here uh you'll want to pick up a
25 rock yes
uh
in the
in this street level world that's a
standard
uh size for
how much crack you want to buy um it's a
small little pebble which is broken up
and smoke smoked in even smaller levels
but
yeah that's a that's a typical way which
you can purchase crack you talk about
splitting it up into four
divided evenly in four uh pieces
typically you break it off into little
small pieces and that will be that will
be smoke but i want to emphasize here
i'm not
i'm not saying that this is a
glamorous thing i'm not saying it's a
good thing i'm saying it's a real thing
people should know how this world really
works and why people are drawn to it
that's the important thing to know now
in our so-called drug war
a lot of time it's overlooked why do
people turn to drugs there's a simple
fact it's very pleasant and it's more
pleasant than the other choices that
they have in their lives i think we have
to understand the choices that people
face on that street level before we
start saying well let's go in and
annihilate them or like
like the drug czar says let's go in and
chop off their heads uh like the
drugstore says we need a massive wave of
arrests are any of these solutions in
the so-called drug war likely to address
the real reasons why people are using
crack i don't think so and after having
gone and seen that scene firsthand one
time i think i even think i think even
less so
someone reads your article
they s here or they read a description
things like
as you smoke your second rock it may
strike you that the crack high combines
the best aspects of marijuana and
cocaine what does that mean the best
aspects of marijuana the most
pleasurable aspects that's why people
use these drugs that's why people use
all kinds of drugs alcohol marijuana
cocaine nicotine caffeine these are
drugs that have a pleasing effect on the
brain and there's there's no use in
pretending that that's not true that is
true
after my night of crack i went home and
fell into a light sleep with the lights
on i feared that an air conditioner was
going to fall on my head i woke up tired
alert still a little buzzed filled with
an urgent desire to get to work to make
up for the night's decadence yes and
absolutely this is not this is not a
this is not a pleasant uh phenomenon
especially the more you do it um cocaine
has a it's a stimulant it tends to
make your heart beat very fast
it
makes you paranoid and you see all of
these in in
regular crack users again this is not to
justify the use of this drug but this is
the reality it's very pleasant and it
has these damaging effects i think very
quickly you can see them if you use it
just a little bit as i did you can see
the effects and
they're not very different from the
effects that
that are very familiar to all of us from
from long-term cocaine use and we know
all the stories from countless
celebrities of what the effects of
massive uses of cocaine are crack is
similar i am used about the weird
apparatchiks who wage war on drugs who
claim vindication in the fact that drug
use is declining among the middle class
they are the ones i thought
melodramatically who should who must
smoke crack before it is too late i
muttered dragging a comb through my hair
the headlines today i think bear bear
this this uh this comment out the people
who are fighting the so-called war on
drugs and who don't know anything about
crag
are in fact the ones who encourage the
crack trade far more than somebody like
myself who has used the drug
crack crackdown sends drug prices up my
only quarrel with that headline is it
should be crackdown sends drug profits
up the result of the drug war is going
to be dry to drive up drug profits and
to encourage people to go into the drug
trade that is the consequence of our
so-called drug war to drive up drug
profits
saturday night i was watching cnn's
capital gang and robert novak's outrage
of the week
was you
well hold on and and uh al hunt who runs
the washington bureau the wall street
journal agreed with him a liberal and a
conservative in addition to that
secretary
of the drug czar bill bennett last week
had some rather critical remarks of you
at the hearing
i understand
their indignation because
uh i think i'm one of the first
journalists to come along and speak
honestly and to d and to dissent
slightly from the official propaganda
line on the drug war but i come back to
drug profits there are two approaches
there's an approach i favor which is to
cut drug profits and then there's the
approach of drug war which has the
effect of driving up drug profits that
is the essential choice
the second point i'm not all alone out
there my actions were
extreme in this case because i wanted to
get to the heart of the problem crack
use at the street level but in fact
there are lots of people out there who
say that this drug war is misguided
and that our goal should not be to drive
up drug profits our goal should be to
drive them down let me talk about some
of the groups there's the there's a
group in town called the criminal
justice foundation which is ex trying to
explore more sensible drug enforcement
policies there's the drug policy
foundation which has had a series of
very interesting seminars on capitol
hill about the bad effects of drug
prohibition there's um
kurt schmoke the mayor of baltimore
there's congressman pete stark who have
called for a serious debate about
legalization and other alternatives to
the so-called drug war all of these
people recognize something that i
recognize which is that the the way the
so-called drug war is being waged now is
very counterproductive and if people
don't think it's counterproductive just
look at that headline crackdown sends
drug profits up
we'll go to the phones in five minutes
our guest is jefferson morley he writes
for a living for this publication called
the nation as a matter of fact on the
latest issues front cover you can see a
cover story here contradictions of
cocaine capitalism how does this article
differ from the one you wrote for the
new republic and by the way why did the
new republic ask you to write for them
instead of you doing it for the nation
they're just two different articles one
is a very impressionistic first-hand
account of going out and investigating
the crack scene this is a longer more
historical account of how the drug war
this is the headline there how the drug
war fattens profits in the cocaine
economy and i go go back over 20 years
and look at this and i urge people to
read this article in the october 2nd
issue of the of the nation if you go
back 20 years look at what happened in
the in the mid
in the early 1970s the first time that
we had a drug war when president nixon
declared drug war one thing that nixon
did which is exactly like what the drug
czar is doing today is they had
they treated marijuana and cocaine
exactly the same
both were
alleged to be equally damaging to users
equally uh anti-social drugs the effect
of that was to encourage cocaine
smuggling and here's why
because
cocaine is a more compact drug it's
easier to conceal it's easier to
transport it's easier to smuggle if
you're undertaking the same risk when
you smuggle marijuana and cocaine you
get more profit by smuggling cocaine
therefore the drug war then as now has
the effect of encouraging smuggling it
encourages more potent
drugs like cocaine and crack here's the
front page of last monday's washington
post
uh eleanor randolph's column crack use
a first-hand account a new ground for
the new republic why did your piece end
up on the front page of the style
section of washington post well okay
this is a very good question
i'm not the first guy to use crack
20 million americans 10 or 20 million
americans have used crack um
i'm not the first person to to speak in
the media about its effects 48 hours on
crack street return to crack street lots
of programs like this have talked to
lots of users
why does my article attract attention i
think it's because somebody finally said
somebody finally spoke frankly about
what's going on out there as opposed to
simply following the line of of uh of
government bureaucrats and saying well
we have to speak exactly in this way
about the drug problem secretary bennett
criticized me because i i have a
slightly different view of the drug
problem
than he does
well
that's just america there's going to be
a range of debate secretary bennett says
i'm a defector in the drug war well
since when since when was i signed up
when was i drafted into the drug war i'm
a citizen i'm not a soldier walking
behind bill bennett saluting we got two
minutes before we go to the phones what
was the reaction besides what we've seen
here from the media
from the media i would say that uh 75
percent of the reporters who i talked to
off camera off the record said i did a
very gutsy thing okay but what kind of
attention did you get
this article been called by lots of tv
stations radio stations people want to
hear what's the story we want to hear it
what's your reaction when that happens
my reaction is people are hungry for an
alternative point of view in the
so-called drug war and it's out there
but uh but nobody
nobody
quite wants to take it take it up
because the government is in charge of
the drug war they're trying to get
everybody to fall in line conform follow
the drug emperor and finally somebody's
saying no we don't have to do that we
need a real debate here about what this
drug war is all about and again i come
back to that headline
drug prices and drug profits are up and
they're going to keep on going up if
this drug war is followed the way we're
doing it now
but back to the whole are you surprised
that you got this kind of reaction no
because i think i think there is a real
hunger out there i think there is a real
popular desire for an alternative view
to this drug war people want another
view they want they want somebody to say
hey we gotta approach this thing from a
different way people understand that the
drug problem yes drugs are a problem but
it's also a way of avoiding paying
attention to the deeper social and
economic problems which are underneath
it
first call for this segment we go to
raleigh north carolina go ahead please
hello how you doing today
first thing i'd like to say is that i
agree i think that
the way the situation is now there is no
i can't imagine drugs being any more
available to the public than it is right
now if you legalize it at least you have
some kind of control
over uh
where you sell it and who you sell it to
you don't see a lot of people selling uh
alcohol
like you do drugs because there's no
profit in it once you take the profits
out of it
you get the criminal element out
what i would do though
is watch very carefully
what they do with the profits
from selling it legally i think all of
it should go to re rehabilitation thanks
i couldn't agree more uh it's it's
absolutely time to uh to get the to
start regulating the drug trade instead
of trying to annihilate the drug trade
we need to regulate it we need to get
the profit out of it we need to control
it we need to bring it above ground
lincoln nebraska go ahead please
uh i hope this gentleman in this article
wrote the after effects
of the drug yes i did
the people that are selling women
selling their children men gone bankrupt
i can't believe he had to use it to know
what happens
he could just go to a rehab place you
don't have to rob a bank to know
uh what it's like you don't have to
murder somebody to know the effects of
murder i can't believe that
that this would be allowed on television
my word about the euphoria we all hear
about it but what they we need to know
not the euphoria what it does to your
life
absolutely absolutely i agree and and
crack has had a terrible effect on
millions of people's lives and i don't
scan that at all in my article but i
don't the reason i wrote the article was
because i don't think people understand
what the drug is all about and they
don't understand uh they don't know
firsthand why people are turning to this
drug you mentioned
a good point that women selling their
children people going bankrupt again the
reason they're doing that is because
there are high profits in the trade
denver colorado with jefferson morley go
ahead please
a year ago in september dea judge
francis young
came out and said marijuana was less
toxic than aspirin he also found that it
was not considered to be physically
addicting now the media has had a lot of
talk on drug wars but still marijuana is
mixed in with crack on the drug wars
obviously there's two different two
different types of drugs
why don't they look at drugs based upon
their effects how toxic how addicting
something logical
absolutely it's a very sensible approach
to
the by not making any distinctions
between cocaine and marijuana you
actually encourage cocaine use right now
on the streets where i out on the
streets where where i saw the crack
trade it is just as difficult to get a
mild drug like marijuana as it is to get
a very potent drug like crack if you're
somebody in those circumstances who
simply wants to get high it's the
current law enforcement system makes it
worth your while encourages you to buy
crack if it were easier to buy marijuana
some of those people might stay away
from the far more dangerous drug
in preference to the milder drug but
again this is something that under the
current so-called drug war it's
impermissible to say
pittsburgh you're next good morning
i'm a little nervous so i hope you'll
forgive me
i've heard mr morley before on facebook
and he's he reminds me he seems to me to
be a very angry man
i want to take issue with him about
he was saying about blaming social or
economic conditions for the drug
uh a problem we have you know i get a
little wary of hearing always hearing
people blame everything but themselves
for what they do no there's no
accountability it seems anymore you know
if you go out you kill somebody it's
because you're economically uh
in poor economic conditions or or uh
because you can blame that girl who
doesn't hurt who was
dating somebody that uh
that they didn't like
well let me tell you the people that use
that use drugs they know what it does
the social
user knows that he's giving money to the
drug lords and i to to blame everybody
but themselves
is it's ludicrous i'm i'm sorry i
thought she was finished uh i don't i
don't hold uh
i don't withhold uh responsibility from
drug users i say that the goal of
government uh should be to in to make
users responsible for their behavior and
the way to do that is not to say we are
going to annihilate you we are going to
kill you we are going to chop off your
head if you use or sell drugs the way to
the way to encourage
user responsibility
is to bring the trade above ground and
get people to face up to what why
they're using it
richmond virginia you're on with jeff
morley
uh yes um is mr morley concerned about
any uh criminal prosecution of him
due to his uh
investigative journalism in the crack
field and secondly
uh
i've heard crackers is almost
immediately can be almost immediately
addictive were you concerned about being
becoming addicted to crack
uh yeah i was concerned about that and
uh to answer your second question first
um no uh it turns out i'm i'm not
addicted to craig it's long enough time
has passed that i'm sure of that and
this is one thing another part of the
reason why i did the article was to help
de-mythologize it not everybody who uses
it once becomes addicted and i'm exhibit
a and your second question am i
concerned about law enforcement uh
possibilities well i've talked to
lawyers about what my exposure is and
i'm not no i'm not very worried
the reason i i say so is
drugs are coming into miami at the rate
of in shipments of six five and six
thousand kilos
uh bankers in miami are handling uh an
excess of 20 million dollars every
working day in cash
a lot of that attributable to the drug
trade bankers in los angeles are
handling in excess of 12 million dollars
a day in cash again a lot of that
traceable to the drug trade there's a
drug problem in this country and morally
is a very small part of it if uh if sec
if the drug czar or the drug emperor as
i prefer to call him uh
has problems with me and are worried
about my violation of the law well i
think it's pretty obvious that their
priorities are screwed up do you have a
lawyer standing by in the event somebody
tried to arrest yours uh
i'll be well represented san francisco
go ahead please
yes i i thought you characterized uh
bennett appropriately as a drug emperor
and not czar in fact he's but which
emperor i mean
uh
certainly not julius caesar i'd say i
say narrow
because he's kind of fiddling while rome
is burning with this with this terrible
epidemic i mean i saw the hearings on
c-span with
congressman obi
asking sharp pertinent questions to this
bennett and uh here's this man an ex two
pack a day nicotine
uh habit person uh overweight rumpled
a very poor example of uh compared to
dick thornberg who has a clipped
military appearance and you see that man
means business this guy is squirming
around in his chair obie asks him a very
pertinent question when we give all the
money to colombia
for their war on drugs
won't a lot of it come back
uh to pay off
their debt to the banks won't that cash
kind of disappear into their
into their coffers and he didn't even
know the answer to that the man is
ill-informed he sets up an example for
the educators of this country of which
i'm one the educators he was the former
secretary of education if you'll recall
that he's going to go into the
classrooms and he's going to wreak havoc
on the teachers and and gives the
impression that he's gonna he's gonna
sample the urine of every every teacher
in this country nothing could be
calculated to more demoralize our
classrooms and further
uh set a bad example uh for young people
thanks
uh i think your point about about the
drug emperor is is very apt we have this
enormous social problems in our country
uh and especially in our cities
associated with the drug economy and
congress is arguing over whether they
should spend one or two or three billion
dollars more when everybody who has been
in those areas
knows that what is needed is
dramatic improvements in education
improvements in the police force
in all kinds of community
economic development and the drug
emperor tells us that
that one or two billion dollars to go
kill some people and buy some
helicopters in colombia is somehow going
to solve our problems in washington it's
a farce
we're talking with jefferson morley who
is the washington bureau chief or
washington editor of the nation magazine
he wrote a piece in last week's u.s news
and world report i'm sorry yes the new
republic uh called what crack is like
and
describes
an experience of smoking crack will you
smoke crack again i doubt it
dekalb county georgia go ahead please
good morning i do not use or advocate
recreational drugs but i certainly do
congratulate uh the nation the new
republic and jeff
uh they're the two these two rival
publications that generally knock the
hell out of each other but my suggestion
now for c-span is to not make this a
left-wing thing my friends milton
friedman on the wall street journal
editorial page two weeks ago reminded us
that
he told president nixon in 72 about the
self-defeating counterproductive aspect
of what
this drug
prohibition is doing
and so let's let the public know out
there in nebraska that this is not a
left-wing thing we're talking basic
economics here about what happens in in
the drug phenomenon particularly what
happens in the ghetto thanks absolutely
uh and um it's not it's it's not a uh a
left right thing this is uh just it's a
common sense thing almost and we've lost
sight of that in in in an era of what i
would call drug hysteria milton friedman
did point out in 1972 that drug
prohibition was counterproductive uh
that all it served to do was
to drive up profits to drive the trade
underground to encourage the wrong kinds
of drug use
it's been known for a long time and
we've got to get back to some of those
truths that have been recognized by
right-wing economists like milton
friedman by respected mayors like kurt
schmoke by outstanding policy
organizations like the drug policy
foundation the criminal justice
foundation we got to know we've got to
talk sense about what's going on here
manassas virginia go ahead please yes uh
jefferson morley i'm all for you great
job thank you one of the few people i've
ever seen have enough guts to get up
there on national television and tell
people exactly how it is
people fail to realize alcohol is
probably the most dangerous drug that we
have available to us more people are
killed
with alcohol and for any other drug
there is and i imagine that's a very
good point i might add even people in
inner city neighborhoods that have
tremendous crack problems
chemical dependence counselors in those
areas point out that even in those areas
alcohol is still the number one drug
problem even in crack areas uh but this
is something that again the drug emperor
doesn't want us talking about
next call
see here palo alto go ahead please
yeah hi uh i just uh
first of all i agree that uh
we should legalize drugs to get the
profit out of it but on the other hand
the message that he gives that somebody
can casually
come in and out of drugs and take it and
go back out
is very frightening and i wonder how you
think that what would you advise
everybody try it one time or what
no i wouldn't i wouldn't advise
everybody to try at one time but i
advise everybody to face up honestly to
what this drug is that people are using
that was the point of my article not to
encourage use
the fact of the matter is is that uh
we're going to have to trust the adult
population of this country to control
their own drug use if they can't do it
themselves there's no reason why to
think that a drug emperor or the u.s
military is going to do the job the fact
is it's up to all of us as adults to
control our own drug use alcohol
nicotine marijuana whatever and to
control its and to control its use among
our young children but the people of
this country have to take up the job the
the military the police and the drug
emperor can't do it for us
you said that you
smoked crack sometime this year yeah
several months ago
it's not important brian the reason the
fact that no let me tell you why i'm
asking
how did this article all of a sudden
find its way
in at this time in other words did you
originally smoke crack for the purpose
of this article or writing any article
um uh in fact um it had been pointed out
to me by somebody who's very involved in
uh efforts to educate the public about
drugs that we really don't know that
much about how the drug trade works on
the street level about why people are
using it on the street why they choose
one drug over another and that got me
thinking yeah it's time to do it and in
fact i looked around and asked
journalists before i did this article
what do you know about craig how do you
know it do you know people have used it
have you talked to them
have you used it yourself and the
overwhelming answer i came with and this
is among journalists who write about the
drug problem in the so-called drug war
was that the only thing they knew about
it was either through government
pronouncements which are as
pronouncements from governments are can
be propaganda um or from second-hand
testimony of experts in the field many
of whom do know very much what they're
talking about but people did not know
journalists did not know in any
firsthand way about about this
phenomenon so that's when i decided to
set out and do it uh it came about in a
conversation i had with the editor of
the magazine
he was making mike kinsley was making
the same point what do what do
journalists know about crack there's
lots of journalists who know about
marijuana there's lots of journalists
who know about cocaine there's lots of
government bureaucrats fighting the drug
war who know about marijuana there's
lots of government bureaucrats who know
about cocaine but nobody knows about
crack at least not close firsthand and
so that's when i decided to do this
article had you pitched it to the nation
and they said no
no i was working on this large article
could you hold that one up sure uh this
is this is a a longer
historical analysis of how the cocaine
economy has grown up
how the
how the government tried and failed to
crack down on drug bankers how the how
the way that our
drug economy is now set up government
uh government action helps encourage
helps raise drug profits
so they're really two different articles
there's a personal side a personal
investigation and there's a historical
investigation looking at why does drug
wars always seem to benefit
drug dealers pittsburgh pennsylvania
again go ahead please hi brent
um
i'd just like to express an opinion and
get jeff's response which in part i
think he did
uh sergeant general coop
i think
had a high degree of success
in his campaign against both tobacco and
alcohol
essentially because he was honest
i feel that bush
lost the opportunity had the opportunity
to be honest but failed to do so when he
did not distinguish marijuana from the
other drugs
uh i agree and i think that that the
surgeon general's approach to
drug use licit and illicit is exactly
the right approach the problems that
emerge from drugs
are public health problems and they've
got to be treated as such okay that
means our number one drug problem in
this country is alcohol our number two
drug problem
is it's close it's between nicotine and
crack
our number three drug problem is cocaine
use
and so on down the line it's pretty
clear that marijuana is far down that
list and that's the reality it's time
that government officials start
recognizing that reality instead of
trying to force a crazy illogical drug
war on the public indianapolis for jeff
morley yes my compliments to c-span i i
really appreciate you having this
gentleman on
i think it took a lot of guts for you
this gentleman on and for this gentleman
to be on there and i really do
appreciate this and our youth are not
stupid they know what's going on when
they see their peers use this drug and
they see that these their peers aren't
going every one of them's not going out
stealing every one of them not going out
killing people
everyone else not going out doing all
these things that
this bennett fella is you know
presenting
they see it and they know that they're
being lied to they're just being lying
dude this is not the truth this war on
drugs is a farce it's a smoke screen for
something else thank you i really do
appreciate c-span thank you for that
thank you for that comment and i'll make
one more point president bush spoke to
junior high school kids here in
washington last week at hind junior high
and there was an article about the kids
reaction to it and kids are not dumb
they know that the president of the
united states is handing them a lot of
bs and they walked out of there and they
said we've heard it all before it means
nothing it will change nothing it's time
that people started speaking honestly
because even seventh graders know that
the line that the government is handing
them on drugs is just
it does it makes no sense with the world
they know after you printed after this
article was printed in the
october 2nd issue of the new republic
anybody call you up and tell you you're
full of baloney no in fact all i've uh
all i've gotten is uh like i said a
fellow journalist who said that i'd done
a gutsy thing gotten some calls from
people i don't even know saying
write on tell the truth i've also gotten
some expressions of concern from parents
well you know aren't you in fact
legitimating it i understand those
concerns completely i have a kid i i
worry about it i know for drug problems
firsthand from from my own family
experience i'm not minimizing any of
that and i just want to emphasize again
i'm not encouraging drug use i'm
encouraging people to speak honestly
about it and kids will know when
somebody's speaking honestly to them and
they'll know when somebody's speaking
dishonestly to them i'd be glad to go
talk to any audience that the drug
emperor talks to an audience of young
kids and i am convinced that when you
come out of that meeting they'll say
morley was speaking the truth the drug
emperor was the one who was you know
off on cloud nine san diego you're next
yeah i want to make some comments
first i think the war on drugs is a sham
i think it's more a war on the bill of
rights i do not use drugs nor do anybody
in my family use drugs and we haven't
nonetheless what i see is an excuse for
the totalitarians of the right and the
left attempting to wrest power from the
american people
and to establish a
a hysterical situation where they can
say they can abolish and abrogate the
bill of rights we see it's happening in
california we see it happening in san
diego
it is a continuous effort on the part of
the
law enforcement community to bring
itself into a position of power in this
country this is a great danger to all of
us this war on drugs is really a war on
the american people by people in power
in this country thank you sir absolutely
the war on drugs is more dangerous to
the american people than drugs and i
think that people need to take a hard
look at what's what's happened to some
of our constitutional rights in
particular the fourth and the sixth
amendments which are the guarantees
against
illegal search and seizure and the right
to legal counsel in the course of the
war on drugs government agencies the
justice department have
law enforcement agencies have been
chipping away at these rights saying
well this problem is too serious this
so-called drug problem and we have to
compromise these constitutional rights
that's a very slippery slope and the
i think that the caller is absolutely
right we have to be vigilant about these
constitutional rights now what would
your reaction be if everybody that
picked up your article read it said if
morley can do it i can do it
unsupervised gut crack smoked it and had
the experience just like you did well if
that happened that yeah that would be
fine but it's just as likely that
everybody will pick up my article and
say morley's the greatest guy in the
world i think i'll send him 10 bucks
sure it could happen but you and i know
it's not going to happen
am i encouraging drug use i'm not
encouraging drug use i'm encouraging
drug use far less than the people who
are helping raise drug profits right now
i'm not encourage i didn't raise the
price and the profit in the cocaine
trade by one third in the last month
morley's article did not do that
drug prohibition did that raleigh north
carolina again go ahead please
hi
uh i am a chemist
and a senior scientist in an
organization that researches the effects
of drugs i grew up
i was in college in the late 70s and i'm
very familiar with you know that's when
drugs began to really come onto the
scene
i know many drug dealers
and am familiar with many drug dealing
networks
there are literally hundreds of people
involved in all these organizations
yes the government would simply offer a
bounty
a reward
a capitalism
influence
to counteract the
rewards from the
from smuggling drugs
it would be impossible for any
major network to continue to function
people would come forward a typical mule
someone who's driving a load of
marijuana from houston to
raleigh
may get paid five thousand dollars
that's all i have to say
uh
you you want to make it more profitable
to turn in
drug dealers than to participate in the
drug trade there's an easier way to get
the profits out of the trade
and the profits could be cut 90 percent
overnight by legalization that's a
simpler way than uh i think than
encouraging very expensive system of
rewards bounties or whatever
why are you right and everybody else is
wrong
i i don't i don't feel that i'm that i'm
right and everybody else is necessarily
wrong you ask it differently then
what
what is it about bill bennett that
motivates him to do what he's doing to
try to find a solution i think he has a
very since i think he sees the drug
problem i think he wants to run for
president very badly he wants to puff up
his own reputation uh he sees serious
problems and he wants to do something
about that
i'm not convinced i'm right i express my
point of view very forcefully what i say
is let's have a debate listen to all
these callers in a time of so-called
drug war when everybody assumes that the
you know the public wants tougher and
tougher measures most of the callers
here calling and saying we want a
different approach i say let's have a
debate let's have a serious debate but a
serious debate is what scares bill
bennett he's the one who called me a
defector in the drug war
the assumption being at all american
citizens must be good soldiers and
salute the drug emperor well i'm sorry i
declined to do that i think this issue
is too important to have no debate on it
it's time to have a real debate it's not
that morley thinks that he's right and
everybody else is wrong morley says
let's have a debate it's bill bennett
who says hey all you soldiers fall in
line and don't talk about anything
different than i want to talk about fort
lauderdale you're next
yes sir
i go along with this morally 100
i think if they legalize it take the big
money out of it put more money into
rehab centers that the drug problem
would dry up within the year and
i hope he sticks with it
i don't think that um i don't think that
the drug problem is going to go away
immediately but i think if we start
treating it as a public health problem
fund those rehab centers exactly like
you're talking about make sure that
everybody who's got a drug problem and
wants to get treatment can go in and get
it right now 9 out of 10 drug addicts
are being turned away because there's no
money for it and we prefer to send our
money to colombia to do
i don't know what
it's time to treat it as a public health
problem and that's what will enable us
to get the problem under control it will
also do one other thing then we can
begin to turn our attention to the
serious problems of lack of education
lack of job opportunities which seem to
correlate with the drug problem
the article in usa today that we talked
about earlier where you said that
profits are going up and the profiteers
are the ones benefiting from this drug
policy lieutenant commander jeff coronis
of the coast guard says
aerial and merchant smuggling from
colombia have dropped off immensely it's
down to nothing isn't that really a
success story
this has happened before in people have
forgotten but in 1984 1984
vice president bush claimed to have
stopped the marijuana trade in florida
it was an absurd claim it was
immediately denounced by the dea and
these things are short-lived the fact is
our borders are porous uh it's it's
always been able to get it's always been
smugglers have always been proven able
to get drugs into into the united states
yes the the the smugglers are laying low
now but there's no reason to think that
this is going to last forever and the
reason it won't last forever is because
the profits are going up
vancouver washington you're next
yes
hello can you hear me yes yeah
okay i watched this band for six or
eight years and i'm really
happy to have this mr morley on there
i myself had an addiction problem
back in 1980
and i'm no brain surgeon
i'm just a common layman and common
working man
the reason why most these people are on
this stuff
and taking these drugs because they're
unhappy about
life
economic troubles
in this country
a lot of people have jobs that pay
little or nothing they can't live
big business
the youth are cracking down on the union
people and everything
i don't know whether they should
legalize uh
any drugs or not i'm
not really sure about that but uh caller
how did you get off your addiction
well i just was smart enough
myself to uh
figure out what it was doing to my life
and it was fouling up my life
and i wanted to do something about it
now a lot of these people
they're all they're talking is these
drug centers
and i think that's fine
but since i went through eight years ago
i've talked to many people
about this situation
and
as far as these drug centers go if
people want help and take it themselves
i think there's a pretty good rate
but if people are sent
to drug treatment centers
by the courts
or they're on remanded there by their
employees
employer
uh it don't really take a whole because
they don't themselves really desire
or want it
good morning uh i think that that this
man's experience is not atypical yes
there's drug use out there but um if
bill bennett had his way this man would
be sent to a camp uh if he sold drugs he
might have his head chopped off um
what what kind of way is that to deal
with the problem the fact is we have to
have enough confidence in our people uh
in the american people that when they
have a problem they're gonna deal with
it and deal with it themselves the state
cannot do it for them as a writer is
this the most attention you've ever
gotten seems like it
seems like it in your head you're saying
i'm gonna i gotta capitalize on this
somewhere i gotta take advantage of the
fact that i've got the spotlight on me
well i think that uh i i take up uh
i i wanna use the spotlight to make the
point that a lot of people a lot of very
sensible people who know even more about
the drug trade than i do have been
making for a long time mayor schmoke of
baltimore congressman stark from
california the drug policy foundation
these are people saying look we've got
to try something different it's time to
rethink this 20 years of drug war has
doubled the supply of cocaine and cut
the price in half while maintaining
large profits for dealers the whole time
okay after 20 years that's the
historical experience that's what's in
my nation article october 2nd we know
that
okay so now what do we do bill bennett
comes along and says let's have 20 more
years of drug war that doesn't make any
sense to me
jeff morley wrote about smoking crack
something he admits that he has done in
this article in the new republic which
was on the stands last monday muskegon
michigan go ahead please
yes i do you hear me yes ma'am okay i am
with mr morley 100 i'm 67 and a half
years old for five years i've been
hollering legalize it legalize it i used
to have to run and hide from people they
were ready to knock me out when i said
that now more and more are coming out
and saying it caller
have you had any personal experience
with people who have no one
granddaughter tries marijuana once in a
while that's all but
i have a 19 year old granddaughter in
college now she just couldn't even look
at her grandmother when she said
legalize it 19 year old now says
let them have it let's help them let's
legalize it the ones that sink to the
bottom of the barrel and won't give up
let them go we can't do anything for
them also this casual use
that's made me mad every time there's
been anybody with power and money they
get the drug they admit they've had it
what do we do about their suppliers have
you ever heard of one of them being
arrested and put in jail
no
why didn't they go after the casual
users a lot earlier than they've done
we've wasted eight and a half years on
this money down the drain
colin makes a very good point and i want
to i want to emphasize this because uh
the drug emperor and others will say oh
morley he's a fringe extreme he lives in
washington
the grandmother from muskegon are saying
the same thing that morley's saying it's
time for a different approach
athens georgia go ahead please
the problem with the drug war they're
trying to fight it with empty guns
you got to put some teeth in the law
they talk about education education is
fine for the
future but we got to live in the present
this generation now the thing to do with
it
is put some teeth in its lawn we can
open up form over yonder clean it off
and that's where they send the drug
people put them on the ship send them
over there and keep them over there
20 years of drug war has proven that
that approach doesn't work
that you can't ship everybody over that
all you're gonna do is raise the profits
uh if you do put people in jail people
more people come in right behind them to
replace uh the people who've gone to
jail uh in 20 years it just hasn't
worked it's it's a nice idea to think
that we could wipe out all irresponsible
drug use in this country but there's
just nothing in the historical record
nothing in the experience of law
enforcement of the judicial system to
suggest that it is going to work the
night you took or smoke crack you talk
about the different you split it into
the rock into four pieces and you four
different times right
to explain this yes
and i want to read
what you keep on going because as time
passes it's important to understand the
cumulative effect of crack all right
what if there were a drug you're you're
talking about your your knight what if
there were a drug i inquired of the
mirror that could chemically induce
feelings of upper middle classness
it would be attractive to the poor and
wildly popular among those who had no
prayer of ever achieving that
comfortable station in life and it would
be despised by people who had worked
long hard years to obtain that same
mental state without resorting to the
drug it would be popular cheap and the
cause of anti-social behavior it would
be a lot like crack
again the point is
crack makes people feel good and people
who are in bad circumstances in their
life like the people who i met when i
was on the street people who did not
have skills for jobs people who had
been beaten by their husbands
people who
had been displaced from their
communities
they didn't have any better choices and
the the crack high the pleasure the
temporary pleasure of crack was the only
solution that they could find to the way
they were feeling bad in their life
the upper middle class
doesn't use crack i don't use crack
because i have other things in my life
that i can feel good about because i'm
fortunate enough to have good education
good job etc
but for people who don't have those
things crack is the substitute and i
just think that we have to come to grips
with that fact crack is not
crack use is not the sign of somebody
immoral
uh pursuing pleasure that's the pursuit
of happiness that's not necessarily
immoral it can be done responsibly and
it can be done irresponsibly
the fact is is that
tragically it's done irresponsibly by
millions and millions of americans we
have to deal with why they want to do it
not just say you are a horrible person
we're going to chop off your head like
the drug emperor wants we're going to
send you to a work camp uh
that approach does nothing for
for the real reasons of why that person
is
smoking crack manhattan beach california
go ahead please hi good morning mr lamb
mr morley um
i commend you for for your views and for
your uh
for your rogue approach at journalism
however my my concern is is for um
other liberal
journalists
problem with the whole
left party as a whole
is
how do you tend to address your
credibility to the very critics that you
intend to reach um
say more i don't quite understand what
you're getting at well you make some
very good points but but the people that
are gonna
they're gonna criticize you on the right
um are questions are i would imagine are
going to make some serious questions
about your credibility as a journalist
because because i i mean as a as a
journalist i feel like i've done my job
i've gone out and found out something
that people didn't know about and i
think that the the tremendous interest
that this article has generated is
vindication of that approach people do
want to know
what's this like what's this all about
uh because they haven't gotten it
firsthand before so i think as a
journalist i'm operating on a long
tradition of direct involvement in the
activities that you're covering that
goes back to the progressive era as a
journalist i think my credibility is
pretty high i know what i'm talking
about you're 31 years old yes
how many well that's not a very good
question are there a lot of 31 year olds
that you know that smoke crack
yeah sure there's a lot of you know on a
regular basis
that i know
i know a few people who smoke crack on a
regular basis any of them conservatives
i haven't really asked those people
really you know their political points
of view
what i was getting i wonder if you'd run
into any conservatives who are saying
out loud drugs are horrible but
privately are using them i've run into
plenty of conservatives in my life
who
have used drugs and if you've spent any
time in washington and ronald reagan's
washington you know that for a fact fawn
hall told the dea she had used cocaine
that might scandalize some people i
don't think it's particularly unusual
fawn hall oliver north secretary brian
drug use is everywhere among people of
all political persuasions this is not
some liberal thing that you know
diabolical plot decadence or whatever
drug use is everywhere oliver north's
secretary uses used drugs jacksonville
florida go ahead please uh good morning
guys how you doing good good uh very
interesting i just heard you talking
about conservative people and uh whether
they use drugs or not i've friend that
is very conservative and they use the
biggest cocaine user i've ever seen
but that's not what i called
i am a personal experience
which i think uh jefferson jefferson
probably experienced as well when he
went through the uh his um little
episode i agree 100
with what he did
and uh the problem with a lot of people
that are using crack cocaine is there is
no outs for them they are stuck in
in the the urban areas of cities they're
stuck in low-income housing
and uh my me personally i did use crack
i had to uh i knew i had to get out of
it but there was no escape for me um i
was fortunate though i was able to sell
my car to move clear across city
and just escape the environment i was in
that's a problem with a lot of people
and uh
unfortunately uh i feel that they will
be continuing their their problems
because of their environment uh
yeah i think that uh that you you've had
the experience that a lot of people have
had this is a dangerous drug
it's highly potent
and it's unfortunate that our current
system of law enforcement encourages its
use
you were fortunate enough to have the
resources to be able to say i got to get
out of here i'm gone there are a lot of
people who have the same feelings that
you have have the same kind of courage
to face up to the consequences of their
action they simply don't have the
resources to get out those are the kind
of things that we have to be addressing
not
let's go out and kill these people how
long in your opinion will the media
continue to be interested in this drug
story to the extent it has been the last
month
um i think that uh
that over time
as people see drug profits going up as a
result of the drug war there's going to
be more and more demand for a real
debate about what this drug war is all
about and about real alternative
approaches so i think that i think the
drug debate is just beginning i think
we've had a period now where
the government propagandists the drug
emperor want to dictate and dominate
and just want the public to fall in line
and be their soldiers and i think the
public is starting to say no we don't
want to do that we want to talk really
about the way to really deal with this
thing not just the kind of rhetorical
political approach but real life how do
we solve this problem real practical
down-to-earth way would you like to
debate mr bennett i'll debate anybody
who wants to who wants to talk about
this the important thing is and there's
people and there's lots of people who
are more competent than i am to debate
this uh but the important thing is is
that we have that debate because right
now we're not even having that debate i
mean if he called you up and said i'm
going to be such and such a place in
such a time you'd come and take him home
absolutely absolutely no no no no
question no problem at all it's time
that we had that debate
i don't think we're having it anywhere
i don't see it not in the political
system i think out there i think people
are talking among themselves but i think
the media and in the political system
there's this kind of conformity group
think heard mentality oh we've all got
to go along with this when president
bush goes on uh and offers his drug plan
then you know joe biden comes on
afterwards and
talks about even more war and more money
on the same failed approaches that's not
a debate
we need a real debate the kind of thing
that mayor schmoke and congressman stark
are talking about a real debate about
the alternatives uh this idea that you
know should colombia get 20 helicopters
or 50 that's not a real debate about the
drug problem atlanta georgia you're on
with jefferson morley yes good morning
how are you gentlemen fine um i'm very
shocked and appalled at what i'm hearing
and i'm sorry to say that i can't
commend c-span
except for offering intellectual
discussion
but
your policy that you're advocating a
legalization just sort of strikes me as
a rather the opposite extreme
and the point that i was
interested in bringing up to you is
you point out that alcohol is legal
therefore other drugs should be legal
and then you point out that
alcohol is bad because there's a lot
more deaths by alcohol than there is by
crack and other marijuana and other
drugs and i would continue to use it as
a lot more death
by alcohol
because it is legal and is accessible
and if it was illegal that that you
would see a decline in death by that and
right i agree but i don't think that the
logical conclusion of that argument is
let's ban alcohol and go back to
prohibition i think we need to regulate
alcohol we need to educate people about
the effects of its use we need to do
that with all drugs
and we've and the toll is too high from
alcohol and from all kinds of other
drugs but the solution is not to ban the
drug any more than the solution is to
ban alcohol
in my opinion follow up atlanta well uh
yes briefly um
i agree that all voices should be heard
and we should have debate on the issue
however what what scares me is i'm a
college student i'm a member of the
college republicans
and
you know you apparently have gone out
and purchased some crack apparently and
you know have no problem in saying that
it was a journalistic
endeavor
and you may or may not have a point
there some people think you will and
some people think you won't
but
i'm you know in the college environment
every day
and it really scares me
that adults are sending out a message
that to even consider legalizing it
because
what i think that the point that you all
miss
is that there are young people who
really are influenced by this and when
they hear a president or as you like to
call him a drug emperor which i think is
very unprofessional you call him
uh
say you know
you criticize him for saying not to do
drugs and you say well maybe we should
you are influencing the young people and
they said that people should use drugs i
never said that people should use drugs
i said that users of drugs should be
responsible should be held responsible
for their behavior users of alcohol
users of nicotine users of marijuana
users of cocaine users should be held
responsible
caller where do you go to school
i go to georgia state university and
where is that located it's right
downtown atlanta right now from the
state capitol right in the heart of the
city how much drug do you use do you see
among your fellow students well quite
quite honestly
there is a lot of drug use and
down here
a student or anyone can just drive down
peace tree street or ponce de leon
street
in the old district of atlanta and you
can you see drug deals
24 hours a day
it's uh it's incredibly you know it's
very alarming okay
how about alcohol use
he's not there oh okay
riverside california go ahead please yes
thank you i agree with everything you
say mr morley except for one thing uh
i'm not a drug user or anything but i do
think
the law needs to change but i don't
think it needs to be
legalized i think that's the wrong word
i think it should be decriminalized
put back where it was not not put the
stamp of approval on it right no i i uh
maybe i should be more careful in my in
my choice of your words i don't think i
don't have a necessarily of an exact
prescription for how drug enforcement
should turn out but we need to move in
the direction of legalization and
regulation decriminalization of it
turning our drug problem from a kind of
a moral problem a so-called moral
problem into a public health problem
that's the real damage of drugs is not
it's not the use itself it's the public
health consequences that result and the
irresponsible behavior of users we need
to hold users responsible we need to
address the public health consequences
and i think through as you talk about
decriminalization that's the way to go
no this is not society's stamp of
approval on drugs any more than
legalized alcohol is a stamp of approval
on alcoholism no but we need to hold
users responsible and bring the trade
above ground our guest has been
jefferson morley who is the washington
editor of the nation magazine
we still have a little bit of time we're
going to go live in a few minutes to
what is a
hearing on the of the national
commission on aids and this is the first
substantive hearing this year we'll see
there is you look on the screen right
now there is absolutely no one there so
if mr morley is not in a big hurry we'll
continue our discussion actually no one
is not accurate there's someone sitting
up there on the desk the chairman of
this organization is june osborne and
this is an independent body created by
congress to oversee the national effort
against the aids epidemic that
discussion should start
momentarily
next call for jefferson morley guthrie
oklahoma go ahead please
yes sir
in 1984 the national academy of sciences
who richard nixon set up to study
marijuana came back and told
ronald reagan that legalization is the
best thing to do for it
and
he had feeling that he owes the mortal
right that marijuana should not be
legalized so he started busting down on
drugs and he belt wiped out marijuana
but people start shipping in a lot more
cocaine
and the this the way addiction is you
substitute one thing for another when
people went out looking for their pot
and it wasn't there they found cocaine
guthrie oklahoma thanks a lot maybe you
should buy october 2nd issue of the
nation where i tell exactly that story
of how that happened in the 1970s when
nixon went after marijuana and cocaine
in effect stimulating the cocaine
economy encouraging drug smugglers and
drug entrepreneurs to go into cocaine
because that's where the profits were
and wiping out marijuana and it's the
same thing we've gone through this
several times in our history
several two national commissions
in the early 1970s had recommended the
criminalization of marijuana
diverse voices from milton friedman and
others were saying
it's time to it's time to decriminalize
here nixon rejected that advice and the
result was the stimulation of the
cocaine economy
same thing as the study you cite in 84
the continuing effect of these policies
is to encourage the use and the trade in
the more potent the more dangerous drugs
in your
article in the new republic right above
it is a quote from peter jennings
using it even once can make a person
crave cocaine for as long as they live
peter jennings abc world news tonight
september the 8th why did they use that
quote because we live in an era of drug
hysteria
and that's why peter jennings would say
something as silly as that in fact he
hasn't paid attention to the most recent
studies of crack addiction which
indicate that this is not something
that's completely on it some different
totally different totally new human
experience that we understand much more
about crack addiction now that that
crack addiction correlates to the social
and economic circumstances of the user
and is not inherent in the chemical
properties of it and only in an era of
drug hysteria would uh would uh you know
a tv anchorman go on and say something
that uninformed fort worth texas go
ahead please yes sir good morning good
morning mr morley hi i'd like to salute
you on your uh point of view i thought i
was the only person in the world that
thought maybe uh that you know i was i
was the only person thinking like this
there's lots of us
but uh i'd like to go back to mr
bennett's uh uh role in all this uh
before he was confirmed in his position
uh as drug jumper as you usually call
him uh he was a cigarette smoker and one
of the uh
pretty faces on sunday morning uh
confronted him with that he said well
he's gonna have to quit in order to
take this job
and of course uh see uh the fever coop
the uh
surgeon general's then told us that
that's equivalent to
to heroin addiction
and uh
sudden how he he just quit
or i guess he did he doesn't smoke in
public anyway yeah would like for
someone to research how he quit did he
substitute one drug for another
or did he uh you know cold turkey what
method did he use and why in his effort
does he not come forward and simply tell
us uh
us a heroin headaches i wish i'm not one
but uh
i am a nicotine addict why don't you
just come forward and tell us as a
national leader how to quit uh that'll
be my comment i'll listen um i do know a
little bit
mr bennett went to a
kind of health spa resort out in west
virginia that has anti-smoking programs
which you go and spend a couple of weeks
there
you eat better you gradually reduce your
nicotine consumption and so on
which is fine and and uh
nicotine is not a drug i use but i don't
think secretary bennett was immoral for
using it i don't think he was
immoral for being addicted to it um and
i think
that that approach you go somewhere and
you learn how how to
attune your life so that you don't have
to use these substances is the proper
approach notice that uh mr bennett
didn't say the way to solve nicotine
addiction is to ban cigarettes and to
chop off the heads of people who sell
cigarettes of course he didn't and it's
not the solution for nicotine addiction
any more than it's the solution for
cocaine addiction before they published
your article at the new republic how
much
concern was there behind the scenes um
there was some uh the main
expression of concern was on the
question of uh uh you know what is what
what does this open up to is this an
embarrassment to you you know as a
journalist and i said and my editor uh
supported me uh that it's it's important
that people know what crack is like
that's why we did the article and i
think that the the expressions of
concern are sincere and i appreciate
that but um i don't think that's a
reason not to run the article there has
been hasn't there been some competitive
tension between the nation and the new
republic
uh in the past they have different
political points of view but they're
both uh they're both good magazines and
uh mr devasky was ticked off when he
found out they were getting all this
publicity in the new republic uh well he
he has my very long uh historical and
important article in there and i think
i think he that's the piece he wants
carlsbad california go ahead please
yeah i think you guys at c-span deserve
a lot of credit for putting mr morley on
i think you also deserved a lot of
credit for showing the libertarian party
a while back which of course has
advocated
sensible drug positions for quite some
time
uh is it uh surprising to mr morley that
there's so little historical interest
in this discussion uh i mean we had a
cocaine epidemic at the turn of the
century we went through the noble
experiment
uh
the same issue the same issue of the uh
wall street journal that published
milton friedman's letter to open letter
to bill bennett gate and reprinted that
incredible column he wrote back in 72 on
the nixon war
also reminded us of rockefeller's war
which included the draconian
capital punishment
and was a
so i understand it pretty much of a
failure yeah the rockefeller laws which
were harsh laws imposed on
drug offenders in new york state in the
early 1970s has proven to be a failure
and it's a mystery to me
why uh government bureaucrats would come
back to that approach when its failures
have been so well documented i think you
as a libertarian can appreciate though
that
government officials are
often interested more in
aggrandizing and accumulating their own
power than in any uh historical
accounting of the real issues involved
in public policy and that's certainly
the case in in in drug policy right now
drug policy is a way to get ahead mr
bennett is obviously uh running for
president from this platform uh and uh
so it's in their interest to have this
drug problem and this uh and this uh and
this so-called drug war but it from a
historical point of view it doesn't make
any sense great neck new york you're
next ah good morning your last caller
hit my primary issue which is one of
the historical uh use and and the the
misunderstanding of uh the history of
the laws uh i
and usage patterns in the united states
going back to the 1870s 1973 i wrote
on
my senior thesis in college
on this it started out to be a health
care delivery
topic and as i started reading more and
more about drugs
and going back in medical and historical
research i became
persuaded toward
very much the attitude that mr morley uh
has been talking about today as just the
only one that makes sense uh the problem
is that we've lost all perspective on uh
on the history that we haven't learned
our own history and and
everyone
for some reason
seems to concentrate on the current
uh
at the moment drug warfare and the
sociological problems as a
result um tell me a little bit more
about what you found i'm sorry
um
it's interesting that several callers
have brought up the historical
experience because there's a tremendous
desire to obscure what the historical
experience has been i know and i talk
about in my nation article the
experience of the last 20 years the
growth of the cocaine economy how this
has come about but in fact as these
callers are pointing out the history
goes even farther back and people just
don't want to pay attention to what has
been learned in the past century about
drug use take a look at the hearing room
which we're going to very soon you can
see that a number of members of the
commission have arrived
and they are expected to start
this meeting very shortly are you
planning any specific
additional articles or appearances in
regard to what has been a week of
controversy for you
i've been asked to do other tv shows and
want to just keep on talking about it in
an effort to encourage
the debate that is going on out there um
i don't want it's not even a matter of
starting a debate i don't think i think
it's a matter of bringing the debate
into the public sphere so that people
can notice it
because right now
i think a lot of people are being shut
out of the debate a lot a lot of point
of view is being is being not let into
the media and the political system
and i think the calls today reflect that
thank you jefferson morley it's uh
actually let's let me take a look at the
hearing room so that we can see where
they are because i don't think they're
starting yet we're getting mixed signals
um
let me let me ask you a question uh
before we i don't believe they've begun
um or have they
somebody please give me a message uh
what is your reaction to our callers
this morning um i think that that i
think the callers a number of whom use
the phrase i'm with you 100 percent uh
callers from guthrie oklahoma the
grandmother from muskegon michigan i
think there's a lot of sentiment out
there that says yeah we need a more
realistic a more honest approach and it
just needs to be listened to by people
in the media and in the and in the
political system thanks again for
joining us let's go to the hearing room
shortly
i want to welcome those of you who have
come to
participate in the
opening substantive session of the new
national commission on aids
i'm june osborne dean of the school